tony gonzalen whose season debut is not
a good one that was in pittsburgh he
comes home to dodgers stadium tonight
what tony needs to do is what he did
last year and he has throughout his
whole career was just pound the zone
have confidence that his stuff
can live well in the zone if he does
that against these phillies and uses his
defense he'll have a nice night
herrera to lead it off and start in
center field and that's
low ball four that was really close
but he walks and the phillies have a
base runner here in the top of the first
lead off man on and here's one of the
hottest hitters in the national league
gene segura three consecutive
three hit games and multiple rbi's in
all three of those
he lines that one to right field and
it's off the glove of a diving
in kinstree oh doubles going to third
and into second base sliding is segora
and the phillies have
second and third with nobody out here in
the first inning
brings j.t romuto to the plate swung out
and missed he got him to chase and that
is strikeout number one for tony
godzilla
that's the split and that was a dandy
the bottom dropped out of it
he gets the first out of the game one
down and bryce harper coming up
want to have one run in this situation
with these guys on base early
that one's lying toward right field
that's in for a base hit what is it
it's an rbi single for harper and the
phillies have scored a first inning run
in three consecutive games
on top one-nothing here in the top of
the first hoskins pops the first pitch
up into center field where mookie betts
is playing today
calls off taylor not deep enough to get
the job done
two goals with two on and now two out
and andrew mccutchen
breaking ball down and away and that's
ball four so the second walk already for
godzilla here in
what is starting to become a rather
lengthy first inning for the
right-hander
alec balm third baseman comes up with
the bases full of phillies
he struck him out with that low fast
ball and tony
has two of everything in the inning two
walks two hits two strikeouts on the
mound for the phillies the 24 year old
from
california's central coast spencer
howard the top pitching prospect in the
system made his debut last year
this is and he started in the bullpen
then he went to triple a and then they
brought him back up and they've put him
in the rotation and
stop and start and it's just kind of
been a disjointed year for him there is
the howard family all of them
always a thrill for them to get to
appear at dodgers stadium
breaking ball and a call strike three
beautiful curveball
one out that's a proud papa right that's
right it's a good feeling
gavin locks the hitter there's a
curveball hitting the air to center
playable for o'double a couple steps
from the track
makes the catch and there are two outs
good start for spencer howard more than
anything
working quick justin turner coming up
swinging a miss
spencer howard strikes out justin turner
96 miles an hour
and a one two three bottom of the first
inning that was dominant now spencer
howard will come to the plate for the
first time
and a line drive out toward right going
back on it and turned around as
mckinstry
and spencer howard's going to have his
first major league hit
it'll be an opposite field double at
dodger stadium
i don't know if you could ask for
anything better if you're his family
it's a lot of story books happening
right now that's a beautiful thing right
there in segura man at third
two gone swung on a miss strike three
got a
third strikeout of the game for tony
gosselin
and it's bobbled by chris taylor and
everybody is safe
that'll be his fifth error it's his
third at second base
and now the bases are loaded for gene
segura right man right time right
chop it is short for gavin lux goes the
short way and ends the ending
phillies leave him loaded howard will go
to work here in the fourth
they're still looking for their first
hit against howard you know will smith
piece on the high pitch the pitch up he
can hammer
to left center field will smith puts the
dodgers in front
first hit of the game for the dodgers is
will smith's seventh homerun and just
like that they lead
2-1 joe kelly on the pitch for the
dodgers after the bryce harper base hit
a run of righties coming up in the
phillies lineup here dries hoskins
first pitch swinging grounded ashore
a thing of beauty and on one pitch he
gets two
joe girardi sticking with spencer howard
to go to the fifth
taylor will lead off here in the bottom
of the fifth inning see if they can put
some distance between themselves in the
fills
sailor hits a towering front ball
[Applause]
home run chris taylor and it's 3-1
dodgers check out this catch very nice
you got a baseball and a memory awesome
and that is going to do it for spencer
howard who gives up two hits tonight
they both
leave the yard and up comes luke
williams the former dana hills
dolphin the noise that was made when
luke walked out of the dugout
was unbelievable 2-2 is out towards
center field and it's going to drop in
for a base hit
luke williams cheering section has
something to root for there
that is so cool time run is a board for
the top of the order
gonzalez faces herrera
back spinning out to right no big deal
for the phillies and the six the tying
run comes up with one gone here in the
seventh
in the form of bryce harper towering
drive to right center field
that's gone back on it how in the world
is that staying in the yard
i thought it was gone and we were just
gonna see how far up the pavilion
that it would go bryce thought the same
thing and right about now he's
disappointed that that thing
all of a sudden got a parachute on it at
the end wow
all right so still 3-1 and here's
hoskins gets by
smith tracks it down throws them out
and ends the seventh advancing to third
was albert pujols with two outs aj
pollock a chance to score pujols
towering pop up on the infield falter
he's going to wait for rhys hoskins to
make this catch and he has two scoreless
innings under his belt kenley
janssen the dodger closer long time
closer for the dodgers
he's got 15 saves already this season
he's got a three to one lead to protect
first he's got a pinch hitting travis
jankowski
makes the play on a knuckling line drive
that was fading away from it
one pitch one out for jansen top of the
order and oh dubo herrera
grounded a first easy play pulls two up
and
and the phillies down to their last out
it'll be up to gene segura whose
string of three-hit games ended tonight
breaking ball strikes him out at an end
dodgers take the opener with the
phillies